a million dollars a year is only 3 000 a
day now just because you made a million
a year that don't mean you're gonna have
a million yeah because you got overhead
yeah so after the first year of me and i
knew i could make a million the next
year i'm like i gotta make more than a
million so i can put a million up you
wanna have a million in the bank yeah i
want to have a million in the bank so
then i'm like how do i do that how do i
expand my
expand my clothing line
i do collabs
once i get this storefront i'm gonna do
a collab every month i mean i'm gonna
exchange my customers with other people
customers you know if you got a clothing
line we do a collab you get mine i get
yours but one thing that they're going
to know that this is where you need to
go to get it
so i went from doing collapse every
month to where like now i'm doing a
collab like every two weeks who have you
done collabs with so far i mean you've
done a lot so
uh
like i said um
i did two collabs for young thug
about to do a collab with gunna
um i did a collab with my boy assali i
did a collab with betty hibachi i did a
collab with no jumper i did a collab
with west coast customs i did a collab
with once
um
who else
that's like six
a lot it's a lot a lot like exotic pop
you know i grinded so hard and i've been
messing with exotic pop they gave me my
own soda it's probably one of the number
one sodas everywhere you can see it at
any smoke shop liquor store grocery
market anywhere any place detroit l.a
atlanta texas
new york they're everywhere